disparity with the amount of Labor that
women do and that men do men make more
money statistically so you could just
say the men contribute more yeah men
provide value like if it dude if a
dude's paying my right he's not doing
[__] he's not doing [__] around the
house but women also work so they're
also doing a nine to five like maybe a
third so like well I'm saying
statistically men make more money I just
so go ahead so I just wanted to ask all
your statistics and your percentages all
of that where did you find it is it in
the UK is it in the U.S UK and U.S
there's a little bit of a disparity yeah
between the UK and U.S specifically when
it comes to divorce is 64 in the UK and
it's 80 in who carried out
um the government the government studies
how many women 100 women and then ask
them about their life so do you think do
you think if you if you do three four
different studies and they all come up
to similar conclusions we can we can say
that it's around 80 yeah
divorce lawyers divorce court if we get
into statistics from there so we can see
who's initiating the divorces like
someone has to file right exactly
divorce it goes on record so it's 80 of
women that are filing for divorce
how would you improve the situation for
like I feel like you both have like
heard you know thought about this a lot
like what would you say that both men
and women can do to improve the
situation I think a financial abortion
should be legal
what do you mean what do you mean like I
think that if um women have the right to
get an abortion men should be able to
get into financial abortion so they can
sign off all rights and not pay any
child support whoa
let's say that's one thing because the
way it is now like women are
incentivized to get kids off of Rich
guys like the NBA had to issue a
statement saying that women like kept
stealing condoms and I just think that
should be illegal like you shouldn't be
able to legally do great cat to put hot
sauce yeah like I'd say that's one stop
this woman from getting a baby there are
women out there literally incentivized
to try and get a rich man's baby that
was just one story with Drake and one
random lady and it doesn't represent all
women in the world so I understand that
but I do these interviews all the time
so I'll go on the street I'll talk to
Matt like I'll talk to them at random
people on the street random people in my
living room and I've had so many guys
tell me stories of girls doing this to
them go ahead and you your guys opinions
favor a certain side so when you go out
on these Ventures and you ask people you
know what you're looking for you know
what you can personally
we're rigging the game now no I'm not
rigging the game but you're looking for
something can you that's why you're
going out there so you've got to speak
about something I would say I would say
I get more people that disagree to be
honest when I go out than agree so I
wouldn't say I'm like rigging the game
okay but if you if you're gonna have sex
with a woman
[Laughter]
um
there is a there is a chance that that
woman may get pregnant like so if you
have sex with a guy there's a chance you
might get pregnant yeah yeah that's on
you yeah so so if you if you get to
choose not to be a mother he should get
to choose not to be a father equal
ity
responsibility do you think it is for
getting pregnant
yeah it's definitely a yeah that's a
yeah but women have more to whisper
again
[Music]
this is a situation of grape you let the
man inside
so how is it so it's your responsibility
if you get pregnant even though it's
it's no I said huge responsibility for
it to get pregnant all of the power is
within the woman's hands you have the
right to say yes or no once you do say
yes or no you have the right to keep the
baby you have the right to either
um put the baby up for adoption you have
the right to put the man on child
support we also have birth control you
can get an IUD it's like
99.99s aren't great though birth control
isn't great to be but I'm saying that's
a better option than what men have or
you can require them and you sleep with
wear a condom so it's like I'm saying we
have all the power when it comes to sex
and who who gives birth and who picks
who is born yeah nowadays A Woman's I
feel like a woman's really only going to
have a kid if you like really wants to
because there's so many ways for her to
prevent that at different stages all
throughout but I also think if there
were more support for women who do want
to have children may not have
necessarily found the right man who
actually wants to have a child with her
if she was able to get more financial
support then she wouldn't feel like she
you'd need to trap a man
that's a horrible excuse me
are you excusing a girl trying to get a
kid off of a rich guy because she
doesn't like I'm not trying to excuse it
but that's what you're doing if like you
know Child Care is really expensive okay
raising a child's really expensive and
it's really hard to do on your own right
yes
you get married and do it but what if no
one wants to marry you did you know that
before
you need to and then maybe well I'm
saying maybe lower your standards you
know what if no one other guys you like
want to marry you you're probably
shooting too high
change how you deal with it just like
just like if a dude's shooting at
Victoria's Secret models and they all
tell them no like he'll probably be like
oh me a joke
what have you like just don't see any
men that you like sperm down her yeah
asexual you don't have any romantic or
sexual interest ever you just want a
baby to live life have a kid well isn't
that selfish to bring to bring a kid
into a situation
sensation it's it's not something I
don't think children need two two
parents no well I think they need a
community
reasons why Society is broken because
women are actually literally running
around thinking that children don't need
two parents if you're a good enough
person you can teach a child by yourself
I just read you a bunch of stats showing
that children that come from single
mothers are statistically at
disadvantage in nearly every category
that's not necessarily and they're going
to tell me oh yeah it's fine it's Raider
Charles I think I think it's equally
selfish if a dude does the same thing
like if a dude if a dude wanted to I
don't know adopt as a single father like
I think that's selfish even if you can't
that doesn't necessarily mean you should
yeah like because you're putting you're
putting what you want above what is best
for the kid I think if you're adopting a
child whether you're a single person or
not I think that's a really lovely thing
to do so because being in the care
system is not fun and if you're a single
parent it's better than having no parent
no one to look after you you've got care
workers in and out all day and also like
I lost my Chain of Thought but an ideal
situation in an ideal situation is two
parents would you not agree with that I
would I would agree that you need a
support system it doesn't necessarily
thoroughly mean it needs to be two
parents you could have four parents you
could have you could have cousins and
aunties who are older do you think
that's having a mom and a dad in the
home I've never had both so I have no
idea I could not compare I think if the
kid has adults who love them and show
that they love them openly and always
then it doesn't matter if it's
specifically a man and a woman or two
parents that raise them so it's a
community so it's someone that shows
love so when all the statistics that I
read they never had a father in the home
there are so many different they've
never had a father in the home okay it
was single they never had a father this
shows that boys and girls need both
their mother and their father to be
fully functioning members of society who
aren't going to be grapists who aren't
going to be prisoners who aren't going
to be you know Misfits but I actually
this is one of the things that I can't
understand why women would argue for
single them and to raise a child by
themselves and then act like it's normal
like it's gonna it's gonna benefit
Society it's gonna it's not gonna
benefit sight when it comes to prison
it's not going to benefit society when
it comes to crime so why do it I think
what you've just said is that you can't
be a normal functioning member of
society if you were raised by yourself
okay but just because you heard it
that's not what he said that's not what
he said so what he what we're saying is
it puts you at every statistical
disadvantage so why would you push that
in a society yeah I don't think
personally I'm not speaking to everyone
else I'm not pushing it but if that's
your best bet like you know then yeah
that's all you can do is your best and
if you're doing your best then like what
else can you give me
your person
there's always a guy that's going to
marry you like I'm sorry one out of
three men are either versions or haven't
had sex in the last year or so the issue
is just like the guys that girls want
don't want them and so I think the the
solution is getting a guy on your level
I feel like the thing with the parents
the kids the mothers I feel like kids
are just kids they just arrived here
they don't know anything the only way
from a single parent or whatever is when
they go grow up and then they hear
people talking about it do you have a
joke as a kid you won't notice